[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui mais bon appareil de 26,6 me sa mort
lundi puis cette semaine je veux revenir
sur un peu à peu revenir sur une
tragique que j'ai fait il ya deux
semaines trois semaines et qui m'a
beaucoup avec tout ce qui s'est passé
présentement les médias sociaux dans
l'univers a parlé de dominance narrative
la dominance narratif c'est souvent un
peu jeune et qu'on a vécu d'avoir été
dans la colonisation que un pan
d'histoire et défavorisées l'histoire
était plus raconté dont l'histoire est
écrite qui exclut souvent les histoires
des autres nations mais celles qui ont
une histoire beaucoup plus 11e donc
pourquoi on parle pas des histoires des
communautés autochtones des peuples
autochtones au canada
l'absence au site et d'enfants des fois
de l'histoire des femmes de l'histoire
des personnes afro descendantes des
immigrantes dans le grand narratif
comment
qui domine justement dans l'histoire par
exemple au canada ça je donne juste
exemple canadien parce qu'on pourra
faire ça un peu partout dans le monde
d'ailleurs on découvre de plus en plus
dans toutes les histoires
des personnages compagnie est évidemment
par le passé mais finalement ça faire je
dirais grands de la scène parce qu'on
commence à s'intéresser justement à
l'histoire de l'autre et bien au canada
un des enjeux qu'on avait pour vous
parler de dominance narrative la semaine
c'était le coup comscore le floor de
grand mère qui a ses origines dans les
échanges que les communautés chrétiennes
et les communautés autochtones dans
l'ouest particulièrement écrit lé et
donc que cette couleur là le floral qui
était aussi un design est très apprécié
par les communautés autochtones partout
en amérique du nord eh bien pourquoi ces
foulards là commence à faire partie de
la rega de beaucoup de nations
autochtones dont moi j'ai beaucoup de
coups comme score chez nous mais ce
n'est pas le seul fleuve de g sauf que 1
1 prenant justement une histoire des
familles chrétiennes des échanges comme
compris comme elles s'étaient rendues
justement ce qui était fantastique avec
le discours du nouveau comme cela c'est
que même ma connaissance de l'origine
des fleurs craignait aux remontées
jusqu'à même ses origines de rome sont
eux aussi vie communauté normale qui
existe en europe l'ont été aux primes
énormément et keller flore se sont
mélangés dans les cultures de tous chez
françois hollande dans la garde-robe des
innus de la côte-nord c'était
extrêmement intéressant et ça m'a même
fait faire des embranchements un peu
partout parce que je n'ai pas que des
coups comme ça aussi qu'on appelle et
babouche poster qui sont l'équivalent
russe avec des floral russe
j'ai aussi des flores fleuris vient du
japon parce que nos grands mères notre
aimé le fleury et mais justement c'est
la partie floral qui nous à connecter le
foulard et là j'ai découvert d'autres
dans le franchement d'histoire parce que
pour beaucoup de femmes dans l'ouest
c'était une manière de faire de la
modestie à cause de la religion à cause
de la conversion vers les villes cette
foi chrétienne et le pour beaucoup
c'était montrer son
respect face à l'église en couvrant ses
cheveux bien sur cette trame narrative
de en se rendant jusqu'à aujourd'hui
change selon ci avait converti en
premier qu'il était
avec des chapeaux qu'il était avec des
foulards pour dire de couvrir la tête
qu'est-ce que ça l'a transformé puis moi
de mon point de vue la raison pourquoi
j'ai adopté les couleurs soient
ukrainiens russes japonais c'est par le
fait qu'elle quand je suis allé dans le
bois on m'avait une fois donné une
casquette avec un stylet et il restait
coincée dans les branches des arbres et
j'ai sorti de l'oeuf lors de ma grand
mère que je porte depuis que je suis
adolescent j'ai des amis sur matin je
suis pour rien que nous tentons grand
mère portait ça prend une bonne branche
sa cache derrière des oreilles des
petits mouchoirs garde mes cheveux
beaucoup plus en norme envisage donc
pour moi ça avait un sens du territoire
qu'on est bien due aussi au karaté aux
étages souvent un héritage qui soit
c'est des fous large et des couleurs de
mes tantes et des couleurs de mes grands
parents
sont décédés ou que j'ai gardées
précieusement parce que ça venait
seulement de ma famille et je les ai
adopté comme on peut adopter quelque
chose qui vient de sa grand-mère dans ma
perception dans mon histoire dans le
narratif justement de mon identité alors
vous voyez ça a été un peu partout ça
leur humble due à des raisons qu'avec ça
lui fait le chemin de dinars actifs et
beaucoup de personnes nous ont dit
miller on va pas commencer à glorifier
un subtil clairement su qu'il venait du
colonisateur bien des clients non non
moi c'est un assassin
mais
la raison pourquoi je parlais de
dominance narrative c'est que souvent on
fait une histoire pour un objet et dans
le concept des premiers peuples c'est de
ce que moi je ferai une distinction par
rapport à comment je vois l'édition
avoir lieu sur des places publiques avec
des personnes à l'hôpital et des
personnages l'automne versus les
discussions qu'on a entre communautés
autochtones je vois comment cette
dynamique de narration
se met en branle bas parce que quand on
est en cours nous on communauté
autochtone il ya cette compréhension de
l'histoire qu'on raconte
c'est pas une pour faire dominer l'ordre
c'est un partage et ça nous permet
d'avoir une vision plus grande et de la
connexion pendant les ans avec les
autres donc
quand je vois par exemple le fla quand
je vois comment le tabloïd utilisé quand
je vois comment le froid une odeur s'est
vendu jusqu'à moi parce que j'en avais
pas quand j'étais très jeune mais par
les échanges de mails et chose
importante est que ces histoires se sont
mélangés c'est devenu un peu l'idée
pourquoi des courants comme le pain
indianisme qui est souvent critiquée
comme étant l'idée d'avoir une culture
pour toutes les nations autochtones
alors que c'était un cadeau que les
autres nations autochtones avaient donné
aux nations pactole en attendant que le
même plus se reconnecter à la cérémonie
dont ils avaient été arrachées par la
colonisation par les pensionnats c'est
devenu sofres que c'est une dominance
des réparations ce que c'est la vision
d'un autre peuple thiviers sur notre
culture il ya un réflexe par rapport à
ça c'est assez important parce que on
est ce que je suis en train de me faire
dire que toutes nos cultures sont comme
ça s'est chargé de faire une facile
justement tout le partage de la
distinction la saveur culturelle
existante chaque nation et chaque
commune au paiement d'une comme dans la
même nation dans les communautés
différents ils sont peu variés donc
quand je vois ces échanges qui ont lieu
entre communauté autochtone je le vois
ce
respect justement du président actif
mais là qu'on arrive dans un concert oui
il ya une culture dominante qui s'est
imposée il ya des cultures avec lequel
on partage de territoires qui ont eu
aussi des des courants de dominance
narrative sur eux qui ont été imposées
et leur est ce que je suis en train de
le faire dominer ce que mon histoire est
racontée c'est qu'on pose beaucoup pour
que la multitude des histoires soit
racontée pour justement a été bien aidé
civilisé parce que eu une idée d'un
visibilisation derrière ces différences
culturelles qui pour nous était la
richesse de telles différences mais qui
pour d'autres dangers étaient quelque
chose à effacer justement à coloniser
alors toute cette discussion là des fois
je la voyais ça avoir lieu parce que des
vi nations qui sont plus populeuse et
des nations qui sont plus proches aussi
des grands semblent donc leur couronne
narratif devient un peu plus
raconter un peu plus utilisés pour
normaliser chemin des aspects de la
culture donc ce qu'on appelle les
cultures sur la côte à côte et dakota
qui ont beaucoup beaucoup de prudence
culturel parce que c'est celle qui est
utilisée dans les westerns verizon
devient plus l'idée que tout le monde en
a de toutes les cultures autochtones et
de voir si comme c'est un aspect souvent
ça devient l'aspect le plus connu est là
on parle de dominance narrative c'est de
dire comment cette culture 9 à force
d'être répété répété répété
laisse pas de place pour les ordinations
auto pour les autres cultures pour les
autres façons de raconter l'histoire
alors c'est super intéressant à voir
pasteur ont le vent en poupe aussi que
ça là encore un bon jour de cette forme
de narrative qu'on pense avoir effacé
parce qu'on d'économies escomptés à y
regarder l'histoire des communautés
autochtones on voit ces dynamiques leur
ré appareils dans les médias sociaux ont
reçu dynamique leur
secret deux manières différentes et même
utiliser des fois des
bdd lieu compte pour près croire
sécuritaire avec des alliés et bien ça y
est 50 contre recrue rick des formules
d'un dominance narrative et là je parle
de certains discours tenu en ligne sur
par exemple secteur ou instagram et le
le pouvoir de la masse
allochtone et du message que par exemple
des amies féministes allochtone ou que d
aider vous allez alors comme une femme
pour pouvoir le mettre de l'avant vont
allez utiliser la masse de la
compréhension d'une histoire pour
pouvoir aller par exemple annulé ce
qu'ont été annulés ou effacé le message
qui viennent des communautés autochtones
donc en allant signalé en menant de sosa
s'est dit pas satisfait pas alors que
ces communautés la apporte un nouveau
message qui était quand même très
intéressant dans les dernières semaines
c'est aussi de voir que maintenant
beaucoup de gros qui ont les mêmes
problématiques chalon de se faire
effacer au niveau de la structure
narrative commence à créer des alliances
donc j'utilise des exemples parce que
j'ai quoi un petit ou un gros débat
autour de vous pouvez aller voir le mot
clic hashtag goulaine et de voir comment
les alliances hanté communauté lgbt qui
tu es les alliances autochtone et les
alliances de bhl acteurs ont commencé à
permettre justement une plus grande
barrière contre des attaques qui
viennent parfois douteux du type d'offre
dominant qui souvent
blancs ou eurocentré extrêmement
intéressant ça parle quand même de
déséquilibre dans les médias mais ça
parle aussi du message qui ne veut plus
est effacée vraiment plus qu'à travers
les médias sociaux on peut utiliser des
manières de s'exprimer qui ne peuvent
pas été facile donc la distinction
culturelle un peu comme le serbe partage
que je dont je parlais existe beaucoup
plus mène justement doit se protéger
contre un accueil collectif
qui des fois peut devenir très dominant
dans les histoires qu'ils racontent
extrêmement intéressant beaucoup de
chance d'avoir beaucoup aussi de
dépenses qui
on pas été occupé par le passé
par des électeurs dont les électeurs de
le prendre possession ou déplacement que
les autochtones les personnes qui sont
afro descendants toutes les autres
groupes qui veulent avoir justement une
place au tour de celle de parole
commence à prendre mais apprennent à le
faire d'une façon différente parce
qu'ils doivent se défaire justement de
ce système qui sait prendre sa place
quand elle veut mais des fois banques
doivent faire avait justement ce que
nous on est créé pour pouvoir s'exprimer
et exister en dehors d'un cert de parole
ou lana le narratif et souvent
excluant exclusif alors on s'est un peu
compliqué mais je trouve ça extrêmement
intéressant sélection a observé je pense
beaucoup fait pas ce que je fais de la
radio j'ai même si des fois des manières
de raconter une histoire qui témoins
portant différents mais quand même des
chose de différent et que j'ai j'ai
quand même eu la joie d'avoir beaucoup
de gens qui déjeunent je pensais même
pas savais même pas que ça existait et
ça pour moi ça veut dire qu'il ya encore
de la place et des gens pour entendre
nos histoires alors c'est une belle
semaine n'hésitez pas à partager ses
vidéos et ce n'était pas non plus à nous
envoyer des commentaires ou des sujets
que vous aimeriez entendre parler ou
seulement vous aimez les moments
partagés dans une chronique c'est une
belle semaine